ce mardi après-midi la direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale vient d'organiser donc une
journée dédiée à l'initiation au tennis
plus de 330 élèves yvelinois ont pu
tester leur revers et leur coup droit 7
et au tennis club de guyancourt un
reportage de michael elle me doit
associer le tennis et la scolarité c'est
l'objectif des rencontres
départementales organisées par
l'éducation nationale pour cette
septième édition plus de 330 élèves de
primaire venus de quinze classes ont
frappé la balle ce mardi au tennis-club
de guyancourt c'est une fois par an mais
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
élèves sont initiés dans leur école et
qu'il y as entre les écoles elles mêmes
déjà des tournois des confrontations
cette
manifestation celle d'aujourd'hui à une
plus grande ampleur parce qu'elle est au
niveau départemental et elle consacre
encore une fois tout le travail qui a pu
être fait en amont dans les écoles
quatre ateliers étaient au programme
pour travailler les déplacements la
coordination et la précision avec la
raquette on prenait la balle
on l'a visée en phase avec la main on
faisait tous on fait quoi on échange et
là ballons là on l'a envoyée tu trouves
que c'est dur et d'ici là pourquoi tu
dis ça parce que c'est facile à
rattraper la balle ben j'aime bien qu'on
se fasse des échanges j'ai étiré dans la
balle
après quatre heures de jeu les élèves
ont reçu des récompenses de la part des
éducateurs et pas de classement beaucoup
m'ont demandé pourquoi mais nous on
n'est pas sur le classement n'est sûr le
plaisir partagé tout au long de la
journée et donc ils ont eu des
casquettes avec marquez en souvenir de
la rencontre départementale tennis qui
leur a été offert par du sel
ils on est dégoûtés donc importante des
forces après une telle rencontre
ils ont eu des balles qui ont été
offertes par le club une huitième
édition des rencontres départementales
devraient être programmées en avril 2010
est la ville qui accueillera les
épreuves n'est pas encore connue